that's uh
somebody with a picture of me
in the profile as as you all know
i'm a sucker for i'm a sucker for
that sort of cheap trick
and so there we go
have i been black in all the games so
far
i think i probably have
seems a bit unfair now
please gives me more opportunities to
play the old reddit attacks
um yeah with knight f3
these lines are a little less dangerous
for
black than than usual doesn't mean that
i'm doing well
it just means that the chances of losing
in the opening
are a little bit smaller
knight c3 i don't know what's the
what's the story here i guess i
could possibly go bishop g7
you constantly have to be worried about
h3
trapping that
and potentially potentially unfortunate
foresee on
on h5 but let's not
uh
let's not worry for the moment
yeah ed6 i feel like usually would take
back with the queen
um actually castles i don't know if my
opponent realizes but this is a very
clever
move my idea was after d5 to go knight
e5
and then after 95 hb5
bishop h5 gh queen h5 i might have some
some counter play on the g file or i can
at least pretend to
but now if i castle then d5 comes
and 95 is no longer really an option
since i've already castle that i can't
use that
the uh the
g file so either i have to castle d5
and 98 which i guess is not completely
unreasonable
or i'll have to go d5 myself
okay i'll play d5 myself
hoping that the knight will be somewhat
misplaced on
c3 in this structure and this
will um yeah sort of justify
the the time that i'm losing
i'm expecting queen d2
quite likely and then i think i'll have
to go knight f6
trying to go knight e4 yeah
seems seems like a reasonable
course of action
um after bishop d3 i have a bit of a
difficult choice now
uh i could go bishop g4 that that seems
unpromising due to 95
um yeah okay so my opponent may be
pretty easy for me
because h3 doesn't take into account the
main thread that i had which was to go
knight e4
now i will probably win a pawn
regardless of what happens yeah i'll
take on g5 now
um yeah there is the possibility that
i'm not
actually winning upon
let me think about this 94 94
bishop d4 knight d5
and if e6 yeah there's queen d8 followed
by
97 and then knight c8 king f8
knight c8 bishop b2 would be one b7
hangs that's i'm promising
but i could i could go with d4
immediately though
94.94 because the bishop hiring some d
on e2 i think i'm moving them on
this kind of move that's very easy to to
miss
because you really really usually don't
want to give up that bishop
but for the price of a pretty
uh pretty juicy pond i think we'll do it
so here's a little trick as well
um yeah now after queen d8 will take an
e2
in between move with tracking i'll force
what i thought was pretty um
favorable simplifications but
now i'm seeing c4
after c4 i'll have to allow
cd5 as far as i can see and
um the isolated pawn on d5 will mean
that i won't have
much advantage at all fortunately
my opponent went for rook t2 which is
not a bad move it's just that
at the present moment something else was
required
now after c4 i could go bishop c6
uh not dc4 rook d1 losing a bishop
but i could go bishop c6 and if rook d1
then i have root dc-8
i keep the the structure intact with the
clear advantage um and now i just have a
safe
extra pawn in the center which i
should be able to to convert let me just
grab a little extra space like f4 here
is
the best um best chance fighting
for some for some dark squares
okay a three i'll go a5 possibly
b4 later on trying to create a
a weakness on the on the green side
i think especially after c4 here i'll
just go b3
i'll just go b4 and
um
yeah um i'll i'll try and provoke
c3 i think before i go b4
knight e5 i'll probably just go [ __ ] b8
for the moment
yeah knight d4 rook
feel my opponent is
running a bit out of plans
and uh yeah
b4 is an idea an accident possibly also
e5 at some point
although i am
not not going to to weaken my structure
there
very lightly
b3 yeah i would
i think i'll jump into c3 now
that i have the chance and then go a4
try and create a weakness that way rook
c1 is a good move
possibly with the intention of knight c2
knight to e2 now
kicking the rock away okay
sucking the exchange is somewhat
tempting but
i don't think that's a that's the proper
thing to do
b4 yeah my opponent is fighting really
well
i'll go g5 now try and fight for some
some of those dark squares that i
mentioned earlier
xc3 is likely to happen
and now i'll go f f6 that's
f4 cannot be played so easily next i
want to go
e5 okay he prevented that by attacking
d5
but if i'll get another chance yeah with
the knight in d4 i'm certainly going e5
and then d4
advancing the pawns and cementing the
weakness
on on c2 which i will now
immediately gobble up
d3 d2 looks like a little
lethal lethal
threat
d2 and then d1 okay uh
very similar to the last game in the
sense that my opponent played
very decently just a tad
too passively